اذا وقعت الحكومه الاثيوبيه وجبات وتحرير
التراي اتفاقا بشان خطوات تنفيذ الهدنه
التي تم اقرارها في جنوب افريقيا لانهاء
حرب استمرت عامين وكشف مصدر دبلوماسي
للجزيره ان الوساطه الافريقيه قدمت
مقترحات لتجاوز نقاط الخلاف بين الحكومه
الاثيوبيه والجبهه خلال المباحثات التي
جرت بينهما في العاصمه الكنيه نيروبي
وتضمنت الاتفاقيه وقفه اطلاق النار
والاعمال العزائيه وانسحاب القوات
الاجنبيه ونزع الاسلحه من الميليشيات
وانفاد القانون واعاده الاوضاع الطبيعيه
الى اقليم وقالها قائد جبهه تجراي انهم
ملتزمون باتفاق السلام وبوقف الاعمال
العدائيه من اجل شعره بينما قال ممثل
الحكومه ان الاتفاق مع جبهه ويلزمهم
بتحقيق السلام
ادي صور مباشره تاتينا الان من العاصمه
الكينيه نيروبي لمراسم توقيع الاتفاق بين
الحكومه الاثيوبيه وجبه تحرير التكغراي
كما اسلفنا